[Musica]
sera prova prova
siete ancora con me tardi lo so ci metto
il meno possibile dai buonasera a tutti
questo sono io in uno dei deserti più
deserti del mondo con poco cibo cime
scatola pochissima acqua potabile con
come compagnia solo mosche come potete
vedere ma una compagnia parecchio
fastidiosa da impazzire e facevo circa
50 km al giorno a piedi camminando con
quel carrettino che si chiama charlotte
e vede rosso ed ero solo effettivamente
ero proprio solo nell'arco di centinaia
di chilometri quadrati e non mi facevo
circa proprio anche qua questo è il
punto non mi facevo cerca la doccia da
una ventina di giorni consecutivi quindi
puzzava puzzavano chissenefrega se da
solo pozzi
però c'è un però ero felice almeno lì
ero felice per scelta è ero lì e uno
dice ma com'è possibile che una persona
comune comune possa essere felici in una
situazione del genere dove va in bagno
dove capita e puzza tutto il tempo è
mangia male anche è poco ve lo dico dopo
però è una delle delle risposte il
cambiamento che è il tema di oggi e
anche un po la follia quando sono stato
invitato per il ted tolto l'onore che è
un onore essere qua davanti a voi
mi hanno detto che l'argomento sarebbe
stato il cambiamento e mi sono detto ok
il cambiamento è perfetto per me perché
io ho cambiato tutta la vita però come
lo spiego come un racconto perché il
cambiamento a diversi sentieri da poter
percorrere quindi era un po incasinato e
loro detto faccio la cosa che fanno
tutti che in tema con quello che anche
abbiamo visto prima a google
faccio un google una ricerca e cerco
pupo la parola cambiamento mi è uscito
questo da wikipedia è la prima scelta
che mi aiuta stato pigro mia colpa prima
abbiamo detto che non bisognava farlo io
è la prima che ho preso però è perfetta
perché nel punto 2
il cambiamento in un momento culminante
nella propria esistenza e il
raggiungimento di una personale
consapevolezza superiore che permette di
non commettere più gli stessi errori
persino evitandone altri anche
intraprendendo un cammino percorso di
dignità ed intelletto maggiori fase
redente che non è da sottovalutare
altro punticino ho capito dove era due
punti da lì il cambiamento
ho detto mai al sono io è quello che
voglio dire massa potrà anche uscire
andarmene via ed è stato tutto spiegato
però diciamo che è meglio se li faccio
qualche esempio
io sono un ragazzo di provincia con la
faccia brutta come potete vedere della
provincia di cuneo e
sin da piccolo sono stato abbastanza
portato per gli sport molto portato per
gli sport anzi pensaci bene alla l'unica
cosa che sapevo fare sono un mancato
diplomato e quindi un mancato laureato
infatti fin da subito ho iniziato a fare
molti lavori pensate a un lavoro e io
l'ho fatto è qualsiasi tipo di lavoro
dal dal cantiere
l'impiegato ha venduto anche coccobello
sulla spiaggia che ero uno di quelli
crollava coccobello ero l'unico che non
era napoletano purtroppo però mi sono
molto divertito e ho fatto anche
giocatore di poker stessa sorte per un
voglio fatti tutti professionista quindi
giocatore di poker
e qui c'è una diapositiva se non ci
credete
ero veramente brutto comunque se vedete
la scodella mi si piglia per il culo
anche il bidello a scuola accettando
citando pieraccioni comunque ero anche
qua e ho fatto veramente di tutto però
mi mancava qualcosa mi mancava qualcosa
e in uno delle delle vacanze che faccio
che volevo fare di solito in italia
arrivavo da un periodo particolare avevo
sentito o letto tiziano terzani la mia
vita stava già cambiando lo alla ricerca
di qualcosa
a un certo punto cercato di fare la
vacanza diversa e meno in più la più
economica è la cosa che è uscita subito
è il francigena che spero che tutti
conoscete comunque un pellegrinaggio
tipo santiago lì son partito zaino in
spalla anni ottanta tutta roba che
costava poco piedi massacrati pieno di
punture di tafani eccetera
a un certo punto sulla via per roma mi
fermo
con la tenda sugli appennini toscani
c'era la luna piena dato affetto luna
piena lupi che urlavano una carriera
così mi sono messo lì mi sono fatto una
tisana e di pino marittimo che lì per lì
sembrava buona in realtà faceva
abbastanza schifo mi sono seduto e ho
detto ma perché il dato che su un
qualche sostengo puzzo di nuovo pozzo
son felice le mie ansie sono andate via
completamente o comunque in questo
momento perché non posso farla questa
vita almeno per un po e da lì son
tornato sotto nato dopo essere arrivato
a roma sono tornato alla mia compagna
che è ancora con me non so come faccia
su tornato e ho detto a lei
sussurrandole puzzolente chissà come mai
nel misto restò sempre cunico che
finisco puzzolente che avevo avuto una
pessima idea e quindi il 13 settembre
del 2013 sul balcone di casa mia ho
spento l'ultima sigaretta perché non
fumatore l'ho chiamata la sigaretta e
condannato a vita e ho detto oh cascasse
il mondo anche se pochi soldi da parte
c'è tra vendo tutto quello che ho io
parto faccio il giro del mondo a piedi
camminando non ero assolutamente esperto
noi che sembra grace non lo ero prima
non lo sono neanche adesso
e quindi l'ho detto ai miei genitori
l'ho detto mio padre ci ha messo un mese
prima di parlarmi è stato un casino un
delirio era diventato il giullare del
villaggio e lo sono ancora non vi
preoccupate e poi 19 aprile 2014
sono partito sono partito con poco
allenamento poca esperienza ma partivo
da l'italia quindi era un po più
tranquillo il cambiamento avvenuto piano
piano perché bisogna abituarsi piano
piano
bisogna espanderlo alla comfort zone
visto che abbiamo anche parlato di
comfort con fronzoni questa sera bisogna
espanderla e fare piccoli passi per poi
allungarla sempre di più all'infinito è
uno esce piano piano della propria con
forza e
tra l'altro avevo chiesto per favore di
primo giorno si parte dal punto zero
eccetera ma per favore non venite in
tanti è venuta persino la rai quindi vi
consiglio se volete far qualcosa nella
vita che che sia pazza folle o comunque
un nuovo progetto cambiamenti grossi
ditelo a chiunque
così se non lo fate ce li mettete la
faccia siete costretti perché sono
andato anche in televisione quindi un
culo assurdo e fatto sta che son partito
come vi dicevo dall'italia questo è il
mio gps che mi seguiva su un live sul
mio sito ho fatto partendo appunto dal
nord italia dal mio paesello fino alla
slovenia la croazia la serbia e la
bulgaria la turchia tutta quanta la
turchia la george e l'armenia d'iran poi
l'india il nepal la thailandia e alla
mala l'indonesia la malesia indonesia
tutta tutta quanta poi ritorniamo
appunto all'australia che vi dico che
sono 3.500 chilometri di nulla per poi
andare in nord america
tutto questo nell'arco di tre anni e
mezzo poi 5 di progetto canada tutta la
west coast il messico che è enorme se ci
mettete dentro d'italia nel messico ci
sta varie volte guatemala dove mi ero
anche scaduto il visto per poi chiudere
il cerchio e arrivare in in europa
spagna francia e di nuovo chiudere il
cerchio pronto tale circa di 35.000 km e
rotti tra cammino è un terzo in
bicicletta perché poi vi spiego il
motivo per cui sono arrivati in
bicicletta e sono successe tante cose in
questi cinque anni tanti cambiamenti
sono sono varie cose che ti cambiano
nella vita sono i luoghi le persone gli
incontri te stesso che può cambiare la
situazione e anche gli avvenimenti
quello che ti capita e devi prenderla
così com'è una di questi cambiamenti una
di queste cose è avvenuta quando sono
arrivato in iran che mi spaventava
parecchio lira mi spaventava parecchio
perché faceva paura dai miti a faceva
paura super super pericoloso entrarci
poi a piedi figuriamoci comunque sono
entrato pieno di militari eccetera molto
gentili
a un certo punto iniziato a farmi male
il ginocchio sinistro ma gonfio così ho
camminato per decine di chilometri
centinaia di km col con quel gonfiore il
dolore per arrivare poi a teheran sono
arrivati sono mi sono fiondato in un
ospedale ea un certo punto c'è un 30 40
persone in una sala e nessuno parlava la
mia lingua io non parlavo la loro
nessuno parlava inglese è uscita
un'infermiera ha detto qualcosa in farsi
tutti quanti hanno indicato un eletto
portante che ho fatto
e tu sei lì straniero da solo 26 27 anni
cosa faccio se la prima volta che se
vengo qua a un certo punto l'infamia ha
indicato me ha detto york quindi tuo
turno in un inglese un po come l'ho
detto io malamente e tutti hanno
indicato me per farmi passare per primo
anche se lo l'ultimo perché lo straniero
ed ero ospite per loro sono ospite sei
un ospite l'ospite va arriva per primo e
questo mi ha cambiato subito ha cambiato
subito la percezione che avevo delle
persone di quel paese dei paesi futuri
ed è stato un cambiamento affidatevi
enorme perché poi io comunque sono
andato ospite per un mese e mezzo quasi
2 in una famiglia iraniana era diventato
uno di loro la barba lo dimostra
ero proprio mischiato tra di loro e amir
che mi ha ospitato lo ringrazio ancora
adesso ha garantito per me proprio per
il visto ha garantito e ha messo proprio
la sua vita perché li metti la tua vita
pre gara
un altro quindi ha rischiato parecchio
lo ringrazio tanto un altro di questi
cambiamenti grossi è avvenuto nella
mappa india è veramente folle quel posto
ti cambia la dentro però uno di quei
momenti che mi ricordo di più l
la sera di natale il giorno di natale
dove di ogni volta che andavo in un
villaggio avevo centinaia di persone
attorno come
come spettatori e sono arrivato in
questo villaggio che aveva abbastanza
pericoloso ma quanto dicevano loro e
dovevo metterla tende da qualche parte
periodo almeno spesso in tenda eppure un
cugino del cugino del cugino che era lì
con me ha chiamato un altro cugino del
cugino del cuscino per poi chiamare un
altro cugino uno di questi cugini era il
capitano di una caserma militare e lui è
stato talmente gentile che metto viene
in amia caserma e ti ospito io così stai
sicuro tranquillo
sono arrivato in questa caserma la
faccio breve era il 25 dicembre natale
il solito non passi così natale loro non
lo festeggiano mi hanno messo dentro una
cella con la tenda perché mi ha detto se
no le scimmie ti rubano tutto e dalle
scimmie non si toccano etici un anno
tutto fidatevi
sono andato del roccella poi alle sette
di sera hanno staccato la corrente la
stacca la corrente e mi sono messo
intorno al fuoco con loro è un passato
il mio natale così l'unico una tale che
mi ricordo l'unico
ringrazio ancora oggi di aver fatto di
aver passato quel natale tra l'altro le
scimmie poi mentre mi mangiavano il
panino che la mia cena di natale mi
hanno toccato da una parte un'altra
scena macinato il panino dall'altra qui
sono stato anche senza cielo per ora
felice
non vi preoccupate la veramente contento
contento come una pasqua si sente che
sono ti amo il terzo e non sono di
ferrari e dopo di che un altro un altro
importante evento un altro continente
che mi ha aiutato un altro un'altra
esperienza appunto riagganciando mia
quello che ero prima era appunto il
deserto australiano
questa era una delle mie tipiche notti
passate in australia per tre mesi e dove
non c'era appunto nulla
ringrazio l'australia perché ha fatto
mi ha creato è quello che vedete con
meno ansie sul petto
sono stato veramente bene ma deve
abituarsi alla solitudine del deserto
non è facile e poi dopo ti piace ma
all'inizio impazzisci parlavo da solo
tanto spesso sempre perché dopo un po
ascoltare la musica che cassano dopo un
po allora inizia a parlare da sola e ho
iniziato anche ad hama ad amare né
stesso cosa che prima non sapevo fare
non credevo di saperlo fare e non invece
non sapevamo alla me stesso ho imparato
me stesso di conseguenza ho scoperto di
poter amare anche gli altri quindi primi
hanno iniziato con me e poi iniziato con
gli altri e prima non pensavo fosse così
è un'altra cosa molto bella è che nel
deserto io soffrivo di insonnia prima di
prima di arrivarci o comunque prima di
partire dopo le notti dove non c'era
niente era tutto silenzio sembrava di
essere su marte non vi addormentate
io mi sono addormentato ho fatto delle
notte incredibile sotto un cielo
stellato e le mosche non c'erano di
notte quindi non avete idea stanchissimo
morente
però mi ha fatto superare mi ha fatto
superare tante ansie
fidatevi che dopo il deserto io ho
imparato a stare molto meglio al mondo
perché casomai succedesse qualcosa nella
vita perdo il lavoro mi rinchiudono in
casa per un per un virus particolare
oppure
fallisco in qualche cosa che è normale
io comunque so che potevo vivere felici
tranquillo con una tenda un po di riso e
acqua non potabile
quindi avevo toccato proprio la base poi
un altro di questi cambiamenti
ovviamente è avvenuto quando tutte e due
le ginocchia hanno smesso di funzionare
da un momento all'altro mi hanno operato
e io sono dovuto in america sono dovuto
ho dovuto scendere un po compromessi di
quando il cambiamenti ti arrivano
addosso completamente dovevo dopo 20 e
rotti mila chilometri che camminavo
non ce la facevo più non ce la facevo
più avevo le ginocchia di un ottantenne
e quindi cosa è successo ha detto cavolo
ma devo smetterla qua devo piangendo
hanno finito il giro come faccio è
semplice la bicicletta mi son preso
tutto quanto il carico che avevo nel mio
carrettino melo sono trasformato qua
sopra ho fatto un carro armato i con due
ruote
il mio fisico ci ha messo un attimo ad
abituarsi però poi era senza allenamento
ma ce l'ho fatta e insedierà ci ha messo
un pelo meno fatte 10 11 ora di fila in
bicicletta per una settimana intera poi
vediamo se glieli sedete ancora per la
prossima da una settimana dopo però è
stato bellissimo è stato un amore e il
cambiamento in questo caso mi è arrivato
mi ha sfasciato io mi sono distrutto
mentalmente pro poi l'ho sfruttata l'ho
sfruttata in modo giusto detto cavolo
ciò la tecnologia che che mi può aiutare
però continua comunque a muovermi con la
forza del corpo e quindi da lì poi sono
arrivato a fare tutto il centro america
e nel ritorno in europa e anche in
italia ovviamente quale doveva c'è la
mia eder che si chiama eder la
bicicletta e e dopo di che sono sono
sono sono quello che vedete adesso il
cambiamento è avvenuto e sono appunto
arrivato in italia questa volta non
avevo chiamato nessuno però alla fine si
sono presentati comunque in tanti
un anno fa ho smesso e per concludere
cosa cosa cosa possiamo fare per
abituarsi al cambiamento
dalla mia esperienza
l'unico modo è allenarsi c'è anche solo
senza far qualcosa di drastico come
questo anche solo d'onda domani nella
vostra vita nella vostra giornata
quotidiana cambiate qualcosa anche solo
di piccolo che in modo che la vostra
giornata diventa un'avventura in modo
che non vi assopite in modo che non vi
sediate sempre sul divano e vedete tocca
volo un'altra giornata andata così
uguale alle altre
e vedrete che l'allenamento arriva in un
periodo come questo secondo me
e sono allenati al cambiamento è
necessario evitare
grazie